it's just past 13 GMT and we begin in
Israel with the U.S defense secretary
has touched down at Tel aviv's Ben
gerion airport on a visit shortened by a
weeks-long protest against the
government's plans to change the
judicial system Lloyd Austin is meeting
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu and
defense minister yo AV Gallant at a
nearby venue before leaving in a few
hours time
there was a confrontation between a
protester and Israel's security minister
itama Ben Greer outside the airport
demonstrators blocked main Junctions
across Israel as part of a national day
of resistance they said they were trying
to slow down traffic in a bid to stop
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu from
boarding a flight to Rome Netanyahu had
to be airlifted to the airport it's
bringing our correspondent Imran Khan
he's joining us live from West Jerusalem
the U.S defense secretary confined to
the airport and the Prime Minister
having to take a helicopter to get to
the airport and run
that's absolutely like it's
extraordinary circumstances uh the the
Israeli Prime Minister has found himself
in he can't get through the streets of
Tel Aviv because Tel Aviv is practically
at a standstill right now because of the
protesters blocking roads and highways
so this was a meeting that would
normally take place in the ministry of
the defense uh that didn't happen so
they had to move it to the airport it
was also supposed to be a longer visit
by the U.S Secretary of Defense Lloyd
Austin he was supposed to arrive on
Wednesday he then didn't he was asked by
the Israelis to actually just keep his
trip to one day that meeting is now over
and Benjamin Netanyahu has actually
tweeted he said today I met with the U.S
Secretary of Defense Lloyd Austin our
common goal is to prevent Iran from
obtaining nuclear weapons a thought
Iranian aggression maintained security
and prosperity in the region and expand
the circle of Peace welcome to Israel no
comments there for on the situation in
the West Bank then in nightly raids
there this meeting through Netanyahu at
least is all about on and trying to stop
around and that tracks with what the
Prime Minister has been saying before
often time when he's under pressure
he'll say the word Iran hoping that that
will be you know a distraction from
whatever's going on inside of the
country uh but Israel is a big receiver
of a big recipient rather of a U.S fund
3.5 billion dollars a year on military
aid alone so certainly that's something
else that they would have talked about
now the prime minister is leaving for
Rome he's due to meet with the Italian
leader on Friday so we'll expect to hear
more uh coming out of that both leaders
seem to be quite sympathetic to each
other
um on Friday but this meeting has now
come to an end and as predicted it was
all about one country Iran you mentioned
a prime minister Netanyahu Under
Pressure Imran you've been covering this
conflict for a very long time has he
ever be ever been under this much
pressure internally
foreign
no I mean he Israelis are generally
quite nationalistic they're quite
patriotic they believe in their system
of democracy so to see people like this
ordinary Israelis middle class upper
class Israelis out on the streets
protesting has never really been seen
particularly at this kind of level on
the Saturday protest we're seeing nearly
300 130 000 people out on the streets
there's an extraordinary number of
people but currently this is a very
elite uh protest movement it's people
who are journalists who work in the
military they're high techs and sector
it's people like that ordinary Israelis
from around the rest of the country
still support Netanyahu because they see
him as a very strong man and they feel
that that's what Israel needs right now
it needs a strong a strong leader so he
still has huge amounts of support and
remember he still has them it's a thin
majority but he still has the majority
in the parliament to try and push
forward uh this judicial Reform Bill
Imran Khan bringing us the latest live
in West Jerusalem thank you Imran
well let's get more on this we're joined
by Jonathan Reinhold he's the head of
the Department of political studies at
bailand University and he's joining us
live from Tel Aviv very good to have you
with us on Al Jazeera just how big a
threat would you say these protests are
to prime minister Netanyahu and his
government
so I would say that they're on their own
they can't uh bring down the government
or stop the reforms but they encourage
uh more and more people and economic uh
investors in Israel and trade unions to
strike and to withdraw their funding and
together it's creating unprecedented
pressure and it is a serious problem for
him because it indicates that even if he
were to succeed in passing the reforms
in the knesset in the Israeli Parliament
he could have incredible difficulty
implementing them
and what about Israel's relationship
with its Western allies the U.S defense
secretary Lloyd Austin is in the country
he's confined to the airport because of
the protest how does you know what are
the Optics of that do you think that
Lloyd Austin this is something that
Lloyd Austin will bring up or the
Israeli government
I'm sure he will mention it but I'm sure
it won't be the focus of his discussion
um Israel's uh relations with uh the
West with the United States and Western
Europe
um have two components one component
will remain stable uh irrespective of
what's going on inside Israel and that
is that they share common interests and
common enemies particularly Iran and
radical Islamic terrorist organizations
and that context the only concern will
be whether Israel is is able to fulfill
its traditional role as uh as as uh an
ally in this regard given its internal
divisions
over the longer term though uh
particularly on the center uh of at the
center left of American politics and the
center center right and Center left in
European Politics the fact that Israel
is a democracy is Central to the
underlying support for Israel and were
these reforms to be passed and
implemented and lead to uh over time the
loss of independence of the Israeli
Judiciary and pose a threat to
individual and minority rights in Israel
that could severely damage Israel's
relations with the US and with Western
Europe
what about the ongoing violence in the
occupied territories Mr Reinhold do you
think that that's something that Lloyd
Austin is likely to say anything new
about on this visit
I think that he will emphasize and hear
it's much easier for the United States
because it's an external issue it's not
intervening in Israeli domestic politics
I think he will
um
progression that Tanya who heavily to
take a uh a cautious and careful
approach so as not to escalate the
violence now normally Mr Netanyahu would
support that approach in any case
however his far-right extreme Coalition
Partners favor a far more robust
approach and that is something that
could set things alight here and that is
something that the US and the Israeli
security establishment would very much
like to avoid and do you think that the
escalation and violence that we've seen
over the last few months is that because
of the new Coalition partners that prime
minister Netanyahu finds himself with in
this government
so
um the Israeli Security Services have
been warning for over a year that the
level of tension in the West Bank has
been increasing at the underlying causes
of that are twofold first of all the
failure to have any progress in in the
peace process and secondly
um the strong sense in the occupied
territories that
um the Palestinian Authority is corrupt
and inefficient and is increasingly
authoritarian so all of those things
together provided a tense situation and
the fact that this government with its
far right uh Coalition Partners has come
in has only intensified that tension
Mr Reinhold it's great to get your uh
insights on this we do appreciate it
that is Jonathan Reinhold joining us
live from Tel Aviv thank you